hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast Hanna I'm
just checking in on you
what's another [ __ ] I just got back from
where the hell was I Phoenix Arizona
home of the sons home of the Coyotes
home with a [ __ ] I don't know
Grapefruit League net break fruit league
whatever instructional league I don't
what the [ __ ] is home of the
Diamondbacks home of the [ __ ] card
bills alright I just got back from there
ok I'm coming home I'm taking a cab
cuz I'm old I don't do [ __ ] uber I
don't do lifts I don't do any of that
[ __ ] alright I'm [ __ ] calling
somebody and they just pull up in a car
I just I'm on I don't I don't do it
right [ __ ] take caps so I pull up to
my house and this is [ __ ] whatever
state truck there but these [ __ ] guys
are in my yard the gates open and one of
the guys got a ladder up to the side of
my house so I just walk in I'm like yeah
hey what are you guys doing then he goes
off God summer finally somebody's home
I'm like what do you mean my wife didn't
let you in he was like no there was no
answer and I'm like then what are you
doing here he goes well you know I keep
coming by there's nobody here I got to
check the meter you know they said you
put a new electrical box you know you
guys are never home I mean what was I
supposed to do I was like I don't know
not coming to my [ __ ] yard what was I
supposed to do every time I go to the
bank the banks closed I mean what was I
supposed to do come back when they're
[ __ ] there yet [ __ ] he just kept
saying what was I supposed to do you're
trespassing you [ __ ] the [ __ ] he
just kept saying what a me you know
something I actually kept my cool though
I just calmly said I don't know not
coming to my yard I go off my if I keep
going over my neighbor's house and he's
not there that doesn't mean give me a
right to go in there he goes why I got
to go over I got to get to the
Paul I mean you know when they changed
the box the only put temporary whatever
[ __ ] things on there I got to put the
right things on there I don't have your
phone number I'm like well whose fault
is that semi fault nobody asked me you
guys never called me or I guess you
couldn't call me but you should have got
from the from the electrician he goes
yeah the electrician didn't give it to
me like oh there you go so the other guy
is grabbing the ladder he takes it down
he's [ __ ] walking out I go you know
what do you want you need to do here he
goes no no you know go get out of here
it's a sec dudes you don't got a [ __ ]
pot now you know what I'm saying is
right [ __ ] walking you just opened
the gate you just [ __ ] walk in
unbelievable I like the other guy the
other guy immediately was [ __ ] you
know he's looking down he knew he was he
was the guy was wrong the guy was
basically like this is like the third
time I come over here nobody ever
answers the door I'm getting sick of
this and he just [ __ ] him know
climbed over the wall I don't know what
gates locked
I don't know how they did it I mean he
had a ladder I guess he just [ __ ]
went right up and over it I mean what
was I supposed to do what you're
supposed to do that's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I ever heard so then I go
what do you need to do he told me what
he'd do I call right when they go down
and do it right I mean he still did what
he stopped I don't know it's the
weirdest [ __ ] response ever well you
know what was I supposed to do so but I
was actually happy that I mean I lost my
[ __ ] on it now thinking about it on the
podcast way more than I did in the
moment and you know I said to the guy
said I'm not trying to be difficult but
you know that's what you're doing here
is it's not right you know it's not just
a show said that and you know it's not
right you got impatient and you just
said to hell with it
I'm just gonna do this anyways and
you're trespassing you know you're
trespassing I don't care that you work
for the state that doesn't you know I
guess you know if my [ __ ] house was
on fire or they the pole or some [ __ ]
there was a live wire hanging from it
then yeah I guess you have the authority
to go
up and over I don't think you can do
that just because you're [ __ ] tired
of knocking on the door nobody answers
anyway sorry so I just got back from
Phoenix Arizona I had the best [ __ ]
time when I was out there ate a bunch of
great food but all basically I kind of
ate mainly down near rum wherever
wherever the [ __ ] Phoenix Suns play
the travelin Riverside Resort Arena
whatever the hell they call it had a
couple really cool meals when I was down
they went to this really good pizza
joint good for the Southwest pizza
you don't mean let's not get crazy here
right and I've got a good burrito down
there I didn't work out at all I was
driving over to see my dog I was
starving I got a [ __ ] whopper with
cheese and [ __ ] burger king and all
freckles is that's it I'm done
officially I'm on the wagon for the
first time in a year like really
hardcore on the wagon like I'm [ __ ]
done there's no drink in in sight other
than water for me I don't know I was I
was I know what happened to me the last
two times I went on the road I just been
under [ __ ] a lot of stress you know
not sleeping with the kid and then I got
to put this new hour together and my
[ __ ] shoulders still messed up
although I finally turned the corner
with it and but you know so I have just
you know I just haven't been able to
work out the way I want to and I swear
to god dude I'm starting to get dad
bought and I have to stop this
immediately I am too goddamn vain you
know you know when you just look bad and
a t-shirt I have a pothead body right
now and I do not [ __ ] like it oh I
forgot to tell you so after dealing with
that guy hey you know what the [ __ ] was
I supposed to do I come into my house
and this is strange odor like what is
that is that some hippy candle what's
going on and I come downstairs and Nia
tells me that a [ __ ] pipe or some
[ __ ] burst the night before and all this
water came out I go you got to be
[ __ ] me you got to be [ __ ] me
and I go okay did you
did you go to the front of the house
like I showed you turned off all the
water now I turned it off under the sink
I'm like oh God okay I'm smelling water
and then I look at my bedroom ceiling
and there's a brown stain just ever so
small and this little [ __ ] crack and
I was just like oh my god not again
please tell me not again so I run
upstairs I shut off the main [ __ ]
thing you know this is this thing about
these feminists they don't want to do
[ __ ] housework anymore but they're
not gonna do the guy [ __ ] either like
knowing how to shut the [ __ ] water
off it's like so what exactly are you
gonna do I can watch Mary Tyler Moore
reruns so it I'm sorry
whatever I'm flying I've run upstairs a
flying out the [ __ ] door I shut it
off and then I you know now I got my
stupid like an iphone flashlight you
know because the [ __ ] guys outside
check in the box it cut off the
electricity the waters off now this is
just basically a glorified [ __ ] log
cabin and I'm going through the crawl
spaces and all this [ __ ] and I'm trying
to find out where this water is coming
from has it collected is to ceiling
going to collapse what is going on and
fortunately I think I think we're all
right and it was also fresh water so I
don't think these guys like you don't to
deal with mold which I don't know if
that makes sense to me I mean it doesn't
also depend on what the [ __ ] inside
the pipe I have no idea I'm sure there's
gonna be a bunch of people tweeting at
me
scaring the [ __ ] on me so that's
basically what I came home to but the
plumber came by change the [ __ ] thing
that needed to be changed hopefully
everything's gonna be all right but I
once again you know everybody in your
house I'm telling you right now needs to
know how to shut off the [ __ ] water
everybody in fact that's the first thing
I'm gonna teach my daughter once she
starts walking around you know what I
mean
when she understands the concept of
water and what it can do to your house
all right and I'm just gonna feel like
look the next time a [ __ ] pool iswhat
the next I'm gonna I'm getting rid of
this house I'm done with it
[ __ ] this house I've had it I've just
had it with this [ __ ] house you know
it's my own goddamn fault what happened
you buy a hundred-year-old [ __ ] house
that has a lot of character you know I'm
gonna sell this [ __ ] house and I am
gonna buy some brand-new home depot tout
no character whatsoever I mean I want it
to look like a [ __ ] food court I
don't give a [ __ ]
as long as everything's brand-new in it
you know don't mind life that people
won't put it together right now still
have the problems but I was literally
when I was in the crawlspace right with
all these [ __ ] cobwebs and all that I
just it just it was it I officially fell
out of love with this house and I was
like you know what [ __ ] this house you
know what you know what you went house
you [ __ ] win you broke me down cool
and Luke you finally [ __ ] dead what's
your dirt doing in boss man's hole
that's what this house has been doing me
the entire [ __ ] time I've lived here
I don't know boss we got to get it out
of there what's your dirt doing the boss
man's yard I I don't know boss
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] anyways home ownership you
know they always show all of the young
couple on TV [ __ ] smiling and all
that [ __ ] they had a [ __ ] show me my
[ __ ] whopper with cheese [ __ ] body
crawling around a goddamn crawlspace of
course what are you gonna walk around a
crawlspace bill so then I [ __ ] thank
God it's all right so then I leave I go
down to take care of all the bills and
all of this [ __ ]
so why the podcast late is late and I'm
like all right I got I got to pick up a
salad or something I got to start on the
right
here and you know typical la thing oh
this is a place I want to be that's a
restaurant that you know forty people
can eat at and there's four parking
spots two of which you know are taken by
the cook in the manager and the other
two were taken by the [ __ ] waitstaff
so as always there's no [ __ ] place to
park and I turned the corner lo and
behold there's a [ __ ] spot and I went
down and turned around like a gentleman
and of course someone else said [ __ ]
that and they made the three-point turn
into the goddamn parking spot took my
[ __ ] parking spot and that and then I
then that was it that was enough all my
meditation everything went out the
[ __ ] window and you know so I had my
first [ __ ] meltdown in a while and in
weeks
my first meltdown in weeks and then I
basically I went from yelling at the guy
who [ __ ] took my took my parking spot
it was my parking spot right he got
there first I saw it first but he
[ __ ] made a better move and again he
box me up like you know he got the
rebound
I went from yelling about him in the car
to myself - yelling even louder about
the electrician - yelling even louder
about shutting the [ __ ] water off the
second is of goddamn problem and then I
found a parking spot and I got out and I
think I was yelling so loudly like
somebody walking by was looking at me
all [ __ ] weird and I don't know
whatever I had a little bit of a setback
but I anybody out there if you'd like to
buy a house with a lot of character oh
is this how this house is a character
I'll tell you it'll have you scratching
your head maybe I'll sell this either
you talk to me about this maybe I'll
sell this [ __ ] house and we'll just
do the do the move into one of those
soulless [ __ ] high-rises
you know you know those things that
people do the empty nesters do well they
just don't want to deal with the [ __ ]
house anymore which I never understood
it's like why the [ __ ] would you want to
live in your house all the kids are out
of there you know you know you got all
this space it's gonna be great now right
now I know
now I know what oh do I know why cuz
this shit's gonna happen
yeah I completely [ __ ] get it now like
I don't give a [ __ ] about a view I don't
give a [ __ ] about you know old school
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about anything
all I give a [ __ ] about is if something
breaks it's not on me how where can I
live like that I might go back to
renting this house is just it's just a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
never again I'm telling you right now
don't ever buy a [ __ ] old house
unless you're handy you know or unless
you just like making your life [ __ ]
difficult I'm telling you this is the
classic this is what me and virzi were
laughing about all week I was how he
makes his life easy and I make my life
difficult
he buys a [ __ ] house the last [ __ ]
guy redid the whole thing he gave me
turnkey I need to be more virzi I got a
I got a I got a I got a [ __ ] do that
my next [ __ ] place I don't give a
[ __ ] what it is I'll buy a [ __ ]
Winnebago brand new though just live in
that right where bill you just don't
[ __ ] parking spots out here I don't
know sorry anyways so I'm gonna be Billy
elliptical head Billy [ __ ] no booze
bag and we've eaten salads and all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and uh you know I got to
get this under control I'm disgusted
with myself you know it's time to walk
in the [ __ ] bathroom mirror and just
trash myself you know take the shirt off
let's see what it is you know it look
like Tom Brady at his first weigh-in you
know when he was a college student just
eating Cheetos he was like a third
string quarterback or some [ __ ] well I
don't was like his face I look like his
stomach just no muscle tone whatsoever
I'm exaggerating but it made I don't
know it's not a it's not what I want
it's not what I want to see you know
what I mean it's Christ it's like my
belly is to the point it's gonna be like
when I stand in the shower my knees
aren't gonna get it wet feet are totally
dry you know I'm about that
you know something I'm not that bad but
that's the road I'm heading on and I was
sitting on the plane today watching all
these [ __ ] people who just destroy
their bodies just getting on the plane
just getting on a [ __ ] plane
they're like winded from walking down
that movable hallway whatever you call
that it's not the tarmac what do they
call that the jet way people could you
put your coats under the seat in nine of
the overhead compartment so we can
expedite the boarding process we still
have a lot of people standing on the
jetway we want to have an on-time
departure and I'm just sitting there
watching all of these [ __ ] you know
just fat [ __ ] walking by there's got to
be something amazing though about living
that way well you know you just always
just you're always eating exactly what
you want to eat you know hey Mike you
want a devil dog yeah dude you want to
get a breed oh sure absolutely what do
you feel like having cheeseburger french
fries is it chocolate malt
you know it's like you basically you're
eating like a [ __ ] eight-year-old
whose parents aren't home your entire
life
you know you know when your parents took
off that was it you went to the enemy
you're eating a [ __ ] Entenmann's cake
or some doughnuts those store-bought
[ __ ] doughnuts those ones where it
was like it was like for plane for
powdered for cinnamon do they still make
those things we had those things all the
time
I used to eat I hate goddamn it I ate
absolute [ __ ] when I was growing up then
you went outside you ran around and just
burned it off you never [ __ ] blew out
your rotator cuff is a [ __ ] seven
eight year old you injury-free brand-new
[ __ ] car you know what my body's like
my body's like this house just [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] I can't wait you know I
think I'm like growing here in a [ __ ]
petri dish now I swear to God I you know
they got to do that like it's gonna
happen man when they
when they can grow all the organs and
they can grow all your [ __ ] body
parts up over again I'm telling you
right now it's gonna be like your body's
gonna be like a I would you know it but
they probably still would look old but
you look like one of those restomod
things you know where it's brand-new
underneath but on top it looks at you
know like in 1960 whatever as any of
this [ __ ] it making sense I mean what
was I supposed to do I mean I knocked on
your door three times and there was
nobody here so I just figured I'd walk
into your [ __ ] yard and put a ladder
up next to your house Jesus Christ you
know what I mean can you imagine if
somebody did that at Ted Nugent's house
how many [ __ ] bows and arrows with
that guy ever and then stupid
construction hat what do you got the
hard hat on for that isn't like that's
gonna help like when you fall off the
ladder that thing doesn't fall off with
you maybe that's why he did it
yeah his hat so [ __ ] tight he wasn't
even thinking anyway so I was on the
road and last night I missed the Celtics
beat the Golden State Warriors holy [ __ ]
I got that game taped I got to watch
that and the Bruins beat the [ __ ] out of
the Detroit right well they didn't beat
him up but they scored six goals man
that's just right with red way so you
know one of the original six they I mean
they play in a hockey town everybody
there's a town out there will you play
hockey there's a town I know where the
hipsters go call bedrock the wallowed
twist twist
let me read some how many goaltender's
by the way cause I watched the
highlights that was every one of them
was a bad goal or your defense just gave
it away you know my condolences to the
all the players on the Red Wings today I
can't imagine how [ __ ] horrific your
practices alright the black tux well you
know I saw when I was in Phoenix I saw
Reggie [ __ ] Mel it's [ __ ] amazing
you walked right by me and I just
watched him waiting for an elevator I
just kept thinking like that guy lit up
the garden turn around
likely and made the choke sign and they
looking he's just standing there waiting
for an elevator totally relaxed totally
chi doesn't need to talk [ __ ] right he's
the [ __ ]
that's Reggie [ __ ] Miller hits at
three steals the inbound pass runs
behind the three wasn't good enough to
get him for two [ __ ] hits another
three pointer turns around looks at
[ __ ] Spike Lee does the choke in the
garden I mean that's the it's [ __ ] do
you ever have to do anything you ever
gotta get to accomplish anything else
after that if I ever did some [ __ ] like
that I'm [ __ ] god sakes if I ever did
some [ __ ] like that you know what I
gotta take this hang on a second all
right I'm back I swear to god it didn't
never [ __ ] it it never [ __ ] that's
you know you know it's edgy I just wish
you could just for one day save one day
of being a kid you don't mean just to go
back for 24 [ __ ] hours and not have
to deal with this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] of
being an adult good [ __ ] Lord you
know what that [ __ ] phone call was
about about some sort of [ __ ] tax
abatement for some [ __ ] I don't even
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
you need to go onto the website and did
you [ __ ] yeah it's an abatement you'll
get money back you know what just
[ __ ] how about you just keep it if
you just keep it can I just not [ __ ]
waste those precious second what a big
[ __ ] get one of the tree falls on me
tomorrow this is one of my last [ __ ]
days and I went to
www.canninsider.com/consulting
oh yeah you're on you're on your proper
time and then a pipe barse Danielle and
the powers that be don't go [ __ ] shut
off the goddamn water and you got a
brown spot you know when you're stealing
you know
makes you a little salty what was that I
was talking about Reggie Miller right I
was just saying if I [ __ ] if I did
what the [ __ ] that guy did I would that
I would have that playing on a loop on
my phone right the video and I would
just walk around holding it up as I walk
towards other human beings would be it
and they you know it's incredible what
the [ __ ] that guy did just standing
there waiting for an elevator all right
let me read a little bit uh what we got
here a little advertising you know the
black tux everybody they're not selling
any of these to that [ __ ] guy from
the the musical there right whatever his
name is Ryan Seacrest the black tux
looking great for a wedding or a special
event has never been easier with the
black tux calm with high quality rental
suits and tuxedos delivered to your
doorstep the black tux is giving guys a
new way no way to rent and get this the
black tux offers free home trying on so
you can see the fit and feel the quality
of your suit months before your event
what kind of a [ __ ] man orders a
[ __ ] tuxedo months before an event
how much is your wife nagging you that
you agree to that [ __ ] [ __ ] 60 days
hey you know [ __ ] March Madness
we're going to a wedding and make you
want to try on some [ __ ] tuxedos no I
don't I'd rather jump out the [ __ ]
window but what's the best part you
didn't ask it's completely done online
no trips to the tux workshop required
the black tux comm lets you create your
look or choose from tons of stylists
select that outfit starting at just $95
these suits have a modern fit you know
it's like the old days where you [ __ ]
yanked up your pants and your ankles
were shown right you did the Charleston
you know people did you know what people
when they were doing that you know what
that you know they were doing they were
built in my [ __ ] house the black tux
calms lets you create your look could
choose from tons of styles selected
outfits starting at just $95 this
already said that [ __ ] and if you
have any questions or issues or issues
Jesus they're gonna [ __ ] be a
therapist they're expert customers
canteen customer care team has your back
every step of the way
how much is the tuxedo and when I was
five after ordering your suit after
ordering your suit will arrive 14 days
before the event that's a full two weeks
to try it on and make sure everything
fits if anything is less than perfect
the black tux will send you a free
replacement right away when your event
is over just drop your rental back in
the mail gross shipping is free both
ways how easy is that to get $20 off
your purchase visit the black tux calm
slash bar that's the black tux calm
slash BER for your $20 off purchase you
know I tweeted about this does anybody
know where people in the NBA get their
tattoos where 90% of them go to get
their tattoos they get their the highest
paid of the for sports I believe at this
point and it you wouldn't know it by
looking at the tattoos Jesus Christ with
the area codes and the hope to [ __ ]
highway signs you know I guess those
could be cool if you if you actually
took the time to like I don't know where
they get them done they look horrible I
don't know anything funny to say about
I'm just always watching NBA hoop and
they just they're all everybody's
scribbled all over you can't make out
anything of what anything is it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
like an NBA guy will get a [ __ ]
tattoo of his baby's face on his neck
then you got to look at that for the
rest of his [ __ ] career open he's
like that guy in the Globetrotters that
also wore a [ __ ] headband around his
neck you remember that guy whatever his
[ __ ] name was anyways blue apron
everyone blue apron not all ingredients
are created equal fresh high-quality
ingredients make a real difference so
it's important to know where your food
comes from I would not want to know
where that [ __ ] whopper which
came from talk about your personal
experience with blue apron I've never
[ __ ] used it but I got to use it now
laughter maybe that's how I'll get in
shape you know I'll be like Oprah
I love Brad you know do one of those
things and maybe I can have a giant
[ __ ] house that doesn't fall apart
you know what I like but time no chance
can anybody pinpoint the year she
officially went insane she's just been
famous too [ __ ] long I think it just
makes you go crazy after a while
everybody's always excited to meet you
they're always giving you a [ __ ]
award there's no way to keep your feet
on the ground and then you just think
everything you're saying is interesting
or exciting to the [ __ ] point you'll
just scream something like I love sit in
a giant [ __ ] yard every time I say
I'm just like what is she doing
Jace's Christ Oprah just go to a [ __ ]
hot dog stance you know standing lying
wait your [ __ ] turn and eat the thing
just do that every once in a while
[ __ ] who likes cookies anything was
[ __ ] you know her cult of women they
just hang on her every word just hoping
maybe this complete stranger on TV she's
the one that's gonna make me happy I
mean that that's the saddest part of
watching one of those Oprah shows I
don't know she does it anymore I'm gonna
pretend the show still on the [ __ ]
air was all those women that sat in the
crowd the [ __ ] look of Hope on their
face you know I always wanted to see you
know what they should have had next door
it was the sea of men that all those
[ __ ] poor women were married to you
know that [ __ ] motley crew of
insensitive [ __ ] that never told him
they were pretty or whatever the [ __ ]
they needed whatever they needed they
weren't getting there that they would go
down into this studio audience that just
[ __ ] sit there with that [ __ ]
like you ever watch one of those shows
with us like 10 [ __ ] and they're all
[ __ ] fighting over some nerdy guy and
that look of hope they have if they're
gonna get the [ __ ] you know get
handed a slipper which means they're
gonna be there for another week whatever
the [ __ ] whatever it is they do they
all had that look on their face but you
know what as much as I'm making fun of
Oprah I also like brick but no matter
how fresh it is no matter how much I
like it if someone was standing in a big
yard yelling that it would make me
uncomfortable and it would take away
from the experience you know it's got to
be weird to be part of our [ __ ] staff
just every once in a while just hear
yelling random things custom stairs
I bet Stedman knows how to block that
out huh I swear she has those giant
[ __ ] houses she probably likes the
sound the echo you know she's like
rosebud level famous Citizen Kane what
the [ __ ] was 800 blue apron everybody
for less than $10 per month no per
person per meal blue apron delivers
seasonal recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals choose from
a variety of new recipes each week all
that blue aprons culinary team surprise
you
that's an Oprah thing we got a culinary
TV surprise you recipes are not repeated
how bad is my act right now that I did
it six times I can barely talk that's
what's called having no jokes so what
you do is you just scream your [ __ ]
throwing it against the wall some of the
[ __ ] that came out of my mouth oh my god
sorry I made a reference to Whitney
Houston drowning in a bathtub like that
that's how desperate I am for [ __ ]
material right now recipes are not
repeated within a year so you'll never
get bored customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences blue
apron has several different options so
you can choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment so you
get deliveries only when you want them
each meal comes with a step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe card and
pre-portioned ingredients and can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less blue
inference freshness guarantee promises
that every ingredient your delivery
arrives ready to cook or they'll make it
right
check out this meant this week's menu
and get your first three meals for free
with free shipping I'm praying to God
they have a [ __ ] they named a [ __ ]
ingredient because I'm gonna scream it
like Oprah by going to blue apron calm
slash bird you will love how good it
feels and tastes you'll love how good it
feels and tastes to create and how much
would Oprah kill this Reed to create
incredible home-cooked meals with blue
apron so don't wait that's blue apron
calm slash / blue apron a better way to
cook only guy left two more alright
blinds.com whether you want privacy or
you jerk off during the day or just
maybe I just want to make a room a
little darker you don't have to take out
a second mortgage to get a brand new
custom blinds from blinds calm yeah why
art blinds
one are blind so expensive you can make
over any room or your entire house just
by adding new blinds and that blinds
calm and app and blinds calm has made it
easy Jesus bill next please mention the
talking points below well yeah I mean
it's the next [ __ ] here obviously gonna
read it after you've read that then read
this blinds calm weinstock calm makes
picking out and ordering brand new
custom blinds fast affordable and
shockingly easy holy they'll walk you
through the measuring and installation
every step of the way and with their
100% satisfaction guarantee if you meet
a mistake if you make a mistake I should
never do this on a travel day you know
once they said 100% satisfaction
guarantee I immediately started thinking
of fast
times at ridgemont high you know it's
seven I 100% satisfied now I wanna I
want a reap front Brad
mister if you don't shut up I'm gonna
kick 100 percent of your ass sorry if
you make a mistake measuring your blinds
or pick the wrong color
or screw anything up with your order
they'll remake the blinds for you for
free you want samples they're free
you like shipping it's free it's all
built into the price somewhere there's a
crying child putting all this [ __ ]
together in a third-world country but
you don't need to think about that you
just close those blinds
you close those blinds and you never
hear them crying well whatever your
level of confidence is in the following
instructions what whatever your level of
confidence in following instructions or
even using a measuring tape the design
consultants at blind calm will get on
the phone with you and walk you through
every step oh my god that's got to be
the worst [ __ ] job ever what do you
do am i over the phone I talk people
through putting blinds up I find it
really rewarding okay now when you're
turning it are you seeing more of the
outside or less well okay then then you
want to turn it the other way yeah turn
it the other way and then yes they'll
close are they closing you are seeing
less of the outside okay okay do you
have any more questions they'll answer
your questions and even send you
instructional videos however you want to
interact you can't get this wrong you
can get made to order custom blinds
without paying custom prices only online
at blinds.com call to action CAPITAL
LETTERS must-read g2 blinds calm and use
pro oh go there's no oh there I thought
that was like some [ __ ] right there g2
the [ __ ] blinds calm there's no
oh in the copy here go-to blinds calm
now and use promo code burg for 20% off
that's blinds calm promo code bar rules
and restrictions may apply see blinds
comm for details
I'm definitely gonna see the details all
of a sudden I don't know where there was
rules and restrictions all right C so C
so I have I've had funny feelings I've
gotten funny looks
I've eaten funny smelling sushi but let
me tell you none of those are as funny
as C so streaming library is stand-up
television and original content
especially not the sushi why do they try
to write these funny why would you do
that Jesus Christ the George Burns right
there
next place next please mention the
following talking points I'm gonna we
see so you get unlimited access to see
sells original series next day late
night til arias stand-up specials I'm
just not seeing the comments comments
today binge worthy classics including
forty two seasons of Saturday Night Live
the entire Monty Python catalog the hit
crowd and more we see so you get binge
words the classics British cult comedy
original series like Hammond quest and
bajillion dollar properties not to
mention the entire SNL library well you
already mentioned it
stop saying not to mention you keep
[ __ ] mentioning how much stop
mentioning that including the new
episodes the day after they air plus C
soap brings brings brings stand-up who
gave me the copy this week to brings
plus C so bring brings stand-up right to
your living room with exclusive content
from today's best comedians on demand
and commercial free including Nick
DiPaolo he's got a killer special on
there sign up now to catch brand-new
stand-up specials from Jena Friedman
Fahim Anwar and sasheer zamata oh my god
but the privileged white males here or
watch your favorite sets from comedians
like louis c.k amy [ __ ] inch and
Hannibal Buress also nicked Apollo's got
one access CISOs content from anywhere
at any time using iOS Android Roku Apple
TV amazon firetv Oh Amazon fire TV I
just can't see
the commas Windows or Xbox one ready for
the punchline
Cecil's just 399 a month no joke less
than 4 bucks per month for all the
comedy you want Anytime Anywhere
ad free just go to see so SE eso Sierra
echoecho Sierra Oscar calm right now to
sign up for two weeks for free with
promo code burro at checkout at sea so
calm spelled se e s o calm promo code
bar C SOCOM promo code bar holy [ __ ] I
never thought that was going to end I
honestly didn't think that that was
gonna [ __ ] in alright 38 minutes of
just absolute [ __ ] for this week people
I apologize you know but I feel like for
me that you know is just some things
that needed to be said alright I don't
want to talk about next
sorry bitched about my house so much
enjoy this next little musical clip here
oh hey by the way you know what I heard
that uh that sneaker [ __ ] that I was
saying actually ended up on some big
sneaker website so I must be getting
[ __ ] trashed on that one you know I
had no idea that you know I knew people
in just sneakers I didn't realize they
weren't told that much you know I
actually bought a new pair of sneakers
this week when I was out in Phoenix I
got the classic [ __ ] shell toast
that's what I got you know because a lot
of people were suggesting that I wore
those [ __ ] you know you know those
giant like just chunky [ __ ] sneakers
that people with feet problem use you
know I don't wear those although I do
have the Steve Jobs New Balance you know
if you look at the Daytona 500 picture I
believe I'm wearing him there I did have
a nice pair of sneakers but I was not
gonna wear them to the Daytona 500 so
maybe I have a little sneaker head make
right maybe I don't know and where the
shittiest pair of sneakers I had to go
down like that [ __ ] track with all
the goddamn oil and [ __ ] all over the
place once again I want to thank
everybody that came up to stand up live
everybody at stand up line I had such a
great time and I don't know
Paul virzi question all week and I just
had a I had a great time so thank you
very much
San Jose improv in two weeks and that's
it please listen to the music if you'd
like and we're going to
a greatest hit from a podcast recorded
in a different time in another year and
something else alright have a great
weekend you can channel I'll talk to you
on Monday hey what's going on it's phil
burr it is the Monday morning podcast
it's 20 past 9:00 on Monday morning a
cloudy day out here in LA as it is the
rainy season and actually has some
guests over here so this is going to be
quiet kind of a quiet podcast because I
also have to do the I have some friends
in town from out of town so we have to
do all the LA [ __ ] and I got to be
honest with you I'm trying to think what
the LA [ __ ] is because I'm still new out
here you know when I lived in New York I
knew what that meant you know that meant
they wanted to go to the top of the
Empire State Building they wanted to go
to the Statue of Liberty Times Square
basically they wanted to go every place
that a New Yorker never goes and so what
my mission always was whenever I had you
know friends coming down to visit New
York City was I immediately tried to
convince them that all the things that
they wanted to see they didn't really
want to see and I like to think I was
doing them a favor but you know part of
it was selfish because you know I'm not
[ __ ] getting on a boat to climb up
into a statue that's looking out into
the ocean you know I mean it's like you
know I don't know that's what we want to
talk about underrated overrated
okay overrated climbing up into the
Statute of Liberty if you can even still
do it with the whole 911 America or
whatever that we live in now I don't
know if you're allowed to [ __ ] do it
anymore
I'm sure they'll let you stay light you
know if you let them fingerprint you and
scan your [ __ ] redness but um anyways
I don't I always feel like when you go
to a city like personally I you know I
want to do a few touristy things but I
want to hang out with the locals because
they always know the good bars and the
restaurants and that type of [ __ ] and
so that's what I used to try to you know
convince people like but it's hard
sometimes sometimes you just gotta given
like when my parents came down and they
wanted to eat at Mickey Mantle's on 57th
or 59th Street and you know you just
can't stop people from doing [ __ ] like
that yeah this is a great burger no no
it isn't it's a great as a touristy
burger and it's [ __ ] 18 dollars more
than it needs to be because when you
look out the window you can see Central
Park
what is wrong with you Mickey Mantle's
yes great let's now let's go get a hot
dog at Wade Boggs the [ __ ] is Mickey
Mantle know about making a burger okay
if you want to go boozing and making me
oh that's a low blow
[ __ ] dead legend what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me I apologize the Yankee
fans over that one I shouldn't and
sports fans in general you know Mickey
Mantle never did steroids did he granted
they didn't exist back then and I gotta
say some it's too bad he did as too bad
they didn't exist back then because we
would have got to watch that guy you
know have the body of a 22 year old
until he was 42 and I gotta tell you
something man after you know just
watching some of these guys get busted
and split you know getting busted for
being on juice you know they always have
that question you know should people who
do steroids be allowed into the Hall of
Fame and I think after the a-rod thing
I'm finally thinking no they shouldn't
and just for the simple fact that like I
just said it's like it doesn't help you
get better it just keeps your body in
mint condition until you like 40 42 and
all these guys would get busted the
second they get off them dead their
numbers go right through the floor and I
don't think it has anything to do with
their skill it's just like you do roids
it's like you become one of the x-men
I'm not really big on those action
movies and [ __ ] but you know those
movies where you know somebody gets
superhuman healing abilities and some of
these slices into his arm
I mean immediately heals up it's like
you're literally doing the real-life
version of that and I don't think it's
fair to guys like ken griffey jr. it
really isn't like that guy quietly hits
600 [ __ ] home runs and I you know kind
of stopped noticing 10 years ago when
all these [ __ ] gorillas were coming
up to the plate I don't know I've said
this before maybe they should have a
special wing you know the roid-rage wing
of the Hall of Fame I have no idea but I
gotta admit I think we're all
hypocritical for giving those guys [ __ ]
because no one gave a [ __ ] about
baseball and then all of a sudden when
McGwire and Sosa came around I was one
of the best years of baseball ever and
everybody made a ton of [ __ ] money
and everybody had a great time and now
we're all acting like our feelings got
hurt because we got to watch people hit
600-foot home runs you know then again
he sends him half a [ __ ] sleep out
here here's something that I actually
read a quote from one of these magazines
I guess evidently Clint Eastwood was
hyping that movie gran gran torino I
know if you guys have seen that movie
I'm sure you've seen the ads for it
where he basically is I get up late
alone you [ __ ] person of another race
I'm a white man and I represent my car
represents back when America was good in
the early 70s I guess when he was doing
the interview for that movie he called I
guess the current generation the [ __ ]
generation and at first it made me laugh
and I'm thinking like yeah Clint
Eastwood obviously has earned the right
to call people [ __ ] and I'm thinking
wait a minute please would is an actor
okay who plays tough guys who never
loses a fight really and if he does lose
a fight no movie it's a fake fight so at
the risk of making my second
sacrilegious comment first trash in the
great Mickey Mantle now I'm going to go
after Clint Eastwood unlike where his
Clint Eastwood I want this is my
question for you guys this week where's
Clint Eastwood got off like where is he
earned the right that he's this tough
guy because like he plays a tough guy I
don't understand that with like actors
like I remember like after 9/11 like for
some reason they wheeled out Tom Hanks
and like that was supposed to make me
feel relaxed as an American and I
remember during that time I was doing a
joke on stage going talking about Tom
Hanks saying he's done so many army
movies he thinks he's a veteran you know
what I mean I thought you did army
movies but he played an astronaut he was
in Saving Private Ryan you know what I
mean and like all of a sudden like he
becomes like all these guys like I said
you know his here's one for you I got
[ __ ] you know friends out here so
we're doing the touristy [ __ ] out here
in LA and I take him down to Mann's
Chinese Theater or Grumman's whatever
the [ __ ] they're calling it now and they
got those they got the hand prints and
the feet prints and the footprints
they're in the the cement and I found
John Wayne I swear to God
John Wayne had the smallest [ __ ] feet
I've ever seen I couldn't believe it
this is a Duke John Wayne this is a guy
everyone's one just thought if he even
breathed on you he [ __ ] knock you in
the next week this guy had like I think
he went to [ __ ] lady gap to buy his
cowboy boots c64 [ __ ] piss the
smallest [ __ ] things he could have
fit both his boots and his cowboy hat
that's how small his [ __ ] feet ax if
you ever go to LA and you go to Mann's
Chinese Theater it's on the right-hand
side
he had tiny little last feet you know
actors are [ __ ] annoying yeah I mean
sit then they put on [ __ ]
and leather jackets and they play these
badasses and it's just like dude you're
a [ __ ] you're an actor if you had any
real fights Clint huh somebody have a
[ __ ] rear-engine the drive-thru at
Burger King and you got out and you
settled the score
maybe yes I don't know what but you know
I don't know I'm [ __ ] but just
[ __ ] annoy me and moving on from that
somebody actually sent me an email that
kind of ties into this right
I'm not saying Clint isn't a tough guy
the guy's [ __ ] ridiculous he's 80
years old he's still lifting weights you
know the way his eyes is squinted he
definitely seems like a badass but you
know I want to see his fight card I want
to see his arrest record you know maybe
he was a juvenile delinquent before he
came up I don't know I haven't Wikipedia
him yet I have no idea but this is just
you know it's just an I don't know why
I'm defending this generation of people
because I'm 40 years old so technically
the only generation that pop culture
gives a [ __ ] about is the young kids you
know which is basically I don't know
what whatever whatever it starts to is
basically once you're over the age of 24
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you anymore as
far as like what music you listening to
anyway so this this woman wrote me
that's uh she wrote me this email and it
said when it let me get down to the blah
blah blah blah blah all this type of
stuff saying really nice stuff to me
which I'm going to blow through here
even though I totally appreciate it and
she was commenting on the guy last week
you know the gun last week I was reading
a story where he was hanging with this
girl most beautiful girl he's ever seen
but she's dumb as a brick and as a
[ __ ] pothead and he can't figure out
how to close the deal with her so this
is what she said she said oh and about
the guy who asked about what he should
do with the with the pretty pothead girl
asked him if he tried to get physical
with her wouldn't he know whether or not
she was interested in a physical
relationship if he had made a move on
her which is a great point because maybe
he didn't and
he said he's probably one of those
hesitant guys that want the chick to
make the first move so typical of today
so I guess that's kind of back in Clint
Eastwood saying that this is like the
[ __ ] generation I don't to be a dick
here but I think a lot of that has to do
with the oversaturation of date rape
movies and these 100% chick tone shows
like [ __ ] Oprah and I mean they got
you so [ __ ] I don't know I don't know
what it is they got everybody so
convinced that women aren't the same
lying sacks of [ __ ] that guys are with
just different genitalia that I think a
lot of guys are approaching stupid
pothead chicks like they're these
princesses that need to be rescued
in other words what I'm saying is you
just [ __ ] bend her over he should
just stick her bag of weed on the floor
in front of our ankles and when she
bends down to get it
he should handle his business all right
that was ignorant there you go that's
the first straight-up [ __ ] ignorant
statement of the week let's get on with
it here this is now the Monday morning
podcast if you're wondering what this
babbling is I do one of these every
single week like [ __ ] Cal Ripken I'm
the Cal Ripken a [ __ ] podcast I can't
remember the last time I missed one even
when I [ __ ] miss one I call up and I
apologize you know does that count
if Cal Ripken missed a baseball game in
the middle of his streak and he just
kind of called in the Orioles and said
yeah sorry about that
yeah buddy called up he called up before
the sixth inning so that counts as him
showing up anyways I do one of these
every week people send me they send me
questions they send me their list of
underrated overrated sometimes they ask
before advice sometimes somebody sends
me a kunti email and they earn the right
of douchebag of the week if it's bad if
it's bad criticism if I deserve it I'll
take one on the chin and also I hike the
stuff that I have going on in my career
okay bill what do you have going on in
your career this week
well I will tell you on next Monday
Monday the [ __ ] is today dan this phone
what's 9 plus 7 is 16th March 16th I am
going to be doing a couple of shows I
believe they added a second show at the
punch line in San Francisco first one
sold really well and last I heard we
were going to add a second show you can
go to punch line comedy club calm I have
all the information I probably don't
even had that up on my website doing
what a [ __ ] I'm going to do that the
end of this podcast by the time you hear
this it's going to be up there hopefully
I'm going to be at the punch line in San
Francisco next Monday night with Joe
bartnik and the shows are at 7 o'clock I
believe they just added a 9 or a 9:30
and that's what I like to do I like to
hype [ __ ] where I have 3/4 of the
information and later on this month the
final weekend of March whatever the hell
those dates are I'm going to be at the
house of comedy and East st. Louis white
people don't be scared it's going to be
a nice mixed crowd you know and you know
just like our president nice and mixed
you know there you go I'm going to bring
in America together and then I got after
that I got the Trump marina when I get
on my [ __ ] website here and figure
out almost you listening to this by the
way on my website because I got a I got
to admit I'm starting on my spate of
MySpace I'm starting to feel like the
survivor of a nuclear holocaust you know
kind of like Will Smith's character and
I am Legend every day every Monday I
will be doing a podcast at the pier down
at the bottom of Manhattan you know and
watch a saber-toothed tiger I don't
understood those [ __ ] lions in that
movie where the [ __ ] did they come from
you know the only Lions in Manhattan are
in the zoo so if everybody zookeepers
all died of whatever [ __ ] disease it
was was that some animal lover who came
up with the end of the world rabies I
have to let these Lions go then get
mauled to death just like he [ __ ]
deserved ok here we go sorry had to do
that until I got to my website
April 4 2009 I will be at the Trump
marina
with uninformed Joe DeRosa Comedy
Central Presents Joe DeRosa every local
bar in Manhattan's Joe DeRosa sorry Joe
if you listen to this I you know good
things come in three
and you only have two good things in
your life all right and I'm one of them
don't ever forget that you [ __ ] half
Egyptian jackass all right get a little
louder a little more angrier Oh what
else do I got I got the funny bone in
Columbus and my Caroline's day got moved
from the middle of May to the last week
of April / first weekend I guess it's
the first weekend in May all right I'm
sure I'm getting emails on that oh my
god I was coming in from Chattanooga
just for your show send me a free DVD I
will when you open your mouth let the
mailman jam it down your [ __ ] throat
okay it's really getting me here um yeah
we're gonna be getting less than the
girlfriend over this but the [ __ ]
makeup on okay audience of one um
anyways oh here we go you know it's
something that really annoys the [ __ ]
out of me parents I don't like former
Fred Boyd date rapists who then have
kids and then sit there and can you know
now because they have a kid I have to be
respectful around them I think I talked
about this last week but I'm going to
talk about it again because it's
happened again I'm sick of you former
[ __ ] loud douche bags you know who
just ruined people's flights you ruin
baseball games basically you like me
okay you're an [ __ ] and now that you
have a kid everyone else has to be on
their best behavior because you ended
your life and the fun in your life
everyone else has to be on your schedule
all right [ __ ] you and your [ __ ] kid
all right if you don't want them to be
around a [ __ ] animal like myself
don't take them out in public okay
that's what they have board games for so
why don't you sit there with your board
game and you dip and ruin your
turtleneck sweater that you don't want
to wear it's the rage for the person
that you knocked up builds up inside of
you why don't you keep
that all right walk out in your backyard
and scream into a bush okay but leave
your [ __ ] kids home because I'm still
single I don't have any kids
and I'm having a good time and I'm not
having you be a [ __ ] wet blanket
because you have this little creature
that only half looks like you all right
okay
coming up swinging all right
I'm playing to the crowd right now I'm
getting laughs on just [ __ ]
deliberately being an [ __ ] I'm really
not in that bad of a mood huh I'm not
single either you know what I mean I'm
not married either
all right so watch your P's and Q's over
there sweetheart never tell you I got my
girlfriend the gayest little [ __ ] I
want to put my makeup on I'm a little
eight-year-old princess women love that
[ __ ]
and you know and you think it would keep
them from heckling you during a podcast
but it doesn't the [ __ ] happiness
only lasts for a few days all right
question number one okay so if you're
new to my podcast I do and this one is
going to be a little short this week I
know I would say that then I end up
doing 50 minutes but uh I'm already up
to 18 minutes I'm going to try to keep
this kind of try to keep this about 30
minutes oh by the way I went down to
Irvine last night and I watched my old
friend from the Chappelle show Charlie
Murphy to a nice hours worth the killer
material that I haven't seen before if
you get a chance definitely check out
Charlie I think he really has a just a
totally original original [ __ ] style
that's great he just goes up there and
he tells these fucked-up stories either
that happened that he invented hybrid
stories that are partially true i don'ti
know what the [ __ ] it was great i sat
there in the crowd like a goddamn fan
and had a great time and that is it so
look at me - other put a little bit of a
[ __ ] great guy I am granite I already
hyped my shows and buried his hype
[ __ ] 20 minutes into a podcast and
I'm patting myself on the back
um all right I do questions I answer
questions every week here in the podcast
so here are some questions hey Bill I
was wondering if you ever had a slow
slow spot in comedy like if you ever had
a period of time when you didn't come up
with any material for a while oh yeah
that happens all the time then it
happens like every six weeks you know or
whatever oh we'll have for a six-week
period but I've learned how to get I've
learned what works for me how to get me
out of those and I think I've answered
this before but I know I have a zillion
podcast so I will answer it again in the
name of comedy what I do to get myself
out of those I take all rules of being a
hack I just throw those out the window
and I'm really setting myself up to get
trash like really bill I never noticed
that you ever didn't take the rules of
hack off with your awful specials no I
just basically I do two things when I'm
in writer's block a I will talk about
current events like that dumb broad with
the eight [ __ ] kids and just
basically [ __ ] that like every comic is
jumping on you know like you ever see
when an animal dies on the Discovery
Channel is a bunch of vultures sitting
around it that's kind of like hack
materials like and I'll [ __ ] fly
right down with my ugly Buzzard head and
I'll take a big chunk out of it I basic
just basically if you're in writer's
block just to hacky [ __ ] about topical
news stuff and also I try to ask my self
what's bugging me right now anything
from my girlfriend just get a bad look
there my girlfriend to like the fact
that I can't come up with any new
material anything that's bothering me
and I just you just kind of use that as
an exercise just to go onstage and just
to be saying something new even though
you know it's hacky [ __ ] that you're
never going to keep it it still feels
good to not be doing all the jokes that
you sick of
and usually they'll end up spinning into
something else hopefully and you kind of
pull yourself out of the mud and and if
all else fails just pick on some fat guy
in the crowd all right now don't do that
don't do that okay didn't we learn
anything from Eddie Murphy in the Klumps
whatever the [ __ ] that model was that
what we called the Nutty Professor you
know what I [ __ ] up I thought I had
all the questions right in a row now I
got a scroll down hey how did you guys
enjoy the music last week because you
like the old school music I'm gonna play
some more we play you uh Ted Heath Elks
parade next week
this is slowly just going to become like
[ __ ] pirate radio I bought two more
records this week I actually bought a
clash record because I felt really bad
about trashing them not trashing I'm
just saying I didn't understand their
music so I deliberately went out and I
bought a bunch of music that I never
[ __ ] with when I was a kid because I
got into ac/dc
which led me into Motley Crue which led
me then down to a really bad road of
glam hair metal that I want to say ended
with Britney Fox but somewhere in there
though I did I did I found Stevie Ray
Vaughan when he did the video for
couldn't stand the weather so I always
had one foot in decent music
but uh basically I totally shut out the
Ramones The Clash unless you know other
than their radio [ __ ] Elvis Costello
this is all [ __ ] I bought this week I
finally downloaded David Bowie that uh
Ziggy Stardust album and I was like you
know this is like one of these great
concept albums that people listen to in
the 70s and I was like [ __ ] this I'm
doing it the way they did it in the 70s
- the drugs so I got my headphones that
I have I do have headphones I have the
big [ __ ] you know but actually for
drums they kind of protect your ears
from the drums and he also can listen to
your iPod which I don't have my dis man
and I plugged it in my laptop and I
listened to the album and I [ __ ] up
was cuz rather than listening to it in
the track order I guess of my iTunes I
had
and you know last downloaded so it kind
of jumped all around the album I kind of
realized when the Ziggy Stardust [ __ ]
killed himself or whatever by the third
song I'm like wow how's David Bowie
going to pull himself out of this [ __ ]
thing and then I realized you know once
again I [ __ ] up with technology but a
[ __ ] killer album and uh I don't know
if anybody has any suggestions of music
from that era you know all the [ __ ] that
I thought sucked like Talking Heads I
kind of liked a couple of their songs
but like some David Burns solo [ __ ] I
found is amazing and to think that I was
in a in a warehouse just trashing him
during that period of my life thinking
that he sucked as I was listening to
Cinderella and poisoned and always a
Tesla I'm not saying they were bad but
that was definitely the smooth jazz of
heavy metal it was John I was just
[ __ ] embarrassing really embarrassing
I think 80s music really gets a bad rap
when you start listening to I don't know
I don't want the [ __ ] I just literally
asked you for advice then and then I
bought a couple albums alright I
actually literally still buy them too by
the way bought a couple of CDs and
didn't even listen to them yet and now
I'm already trying to tell you guys
what's good music from the 80s EDC the
[ __ ] the Moosey inner Mussolini it's
[ __ ] in me I don't know
that's alright let's get two underrated
overrated here or whether you guys want
to our story about revenge huh I think I
ask you guys questions you know it's
like you actually have to say and as you
sit there and nod your head in your
cubicle yeah yeah you know or pump your
fists on your [ __ ] treadmill you know
or just say yes out live out loud in
your middle seat on that Delta Airlines
flight can't you indulge the airline's
right now is there somebody with bad
breath eating pistachios next to you
ever tell you that [ __ ] story unreal
he's eating the red ones too that made
his lips all [ __ ] pink by the end of
it Herick horrific flight alright let's
get to the revenge
where the [ __ ] is it [ __ ] generation
I'm really disorganized this week okay
because I have guests
I have entertaining this week all right
been wearing a tuxedo for three days
underrated over it underrated overrated
where the [ __ ] is the revenge story
goddamn it how this is embarrassing why
don't I just read it I'm just going to
start I'm just going to jump around I'm
just going to jump around
who's that House of Pain um no oh [ __ ]
you I don't know it was I tapped out
during that parry to write movie review
bill I just got back from the midnight
showing of The Watchmen I really don't
know how to review it I'm told it sticks
pretty close to the graphic novel it had
cool special effects great story and
good acting but I kind of felt after it
after leaving The Dark Knight I remember
I was so amazed I didn't have a single
thought run through my head for at least
five minutes after Iron Man and Hulk I
left feeling satisfaction but with this
movie something just kind of left me
feeling depressed after watching it I
think it was the overall message of the
movie was serious told in a totally
ridiculous way anyway anyway I would
recommend it but go with caution if you
don't like comic books and have trouble
following fragmented fragmented
storylines like Tarantino movies I
wouldn't go you know it's a goddamn good
review got right to the [ __ ] meat and
potatoes of it oh and by the way he says
it was directed by the guy who did the
300 story 300 movies so there's a lot of
man ass in it yeah I find that funny
that guy's really like that that movie
300 I mean I thought it was pretty
ridiculous but um the amount of guys
that get pumped after they see that I
mean that literally was Playgirl the
movie I thought I just thought the whole
thing was stupid
Peter's very smart dog ain't good luck
with it
you know what that's like that's like
Beyonce my girlfriend downloaded that
[ __ ] album the name of the album is I
am dot dot dot dot Sasha
fierce alright Beyonce well good luck
with that character it kind of still
sound like Beyonce if you ask me
beautiful gorgeous women woman really
can dance but for her voice whoo Jesus
Christ
horrible punishing you just buck and
polishing you owe her best thing was
when she whipped her head around and
fell down on the stage that was probably
one of the greatest things I think I've
ever seen and a lot of its just
bitterness she's absolutely gorgeous you
know she's totally out of your league
and is there anything funnier than
seeing a beautiful girl just [ __ ]
fall right on her ass you know this is
ridiculous
I'm sure she's a nice [ __ ] person but
you know I see reality is I'm kind of
thinking like this is jay-z's [ __ ]
wife and didn't he stab somebody one
time for something although he did in a
hacky way he walked up and he used the
Godfather line he said you broke my
heart and then stabbed them that's all
alleged why don't I shut the [ __ ] up
okay I will all right here's the revenge
story bill I'm not really into revenge
but if someone [ __ ] with me to the
point where I think about pushing them
off a cliff then yeah I kind of feel
like I have to do something so here's my
story well this is a good one
settle in for this one if you're at home
get underneath your Afghan and roast
some [ __ ] marshmallows because this
is like this is the closest thing to a
ghost story
this just has that evil [ __ ] Last
House on the Left vibe which I love that
they're making again because that
reference will finally make sense to
people if you don't know what that is
there was John Roth films in the 70s
which were basically rape movies Last
House on the Left Gator bait [ __ ] I
Spit on Your Grave and evidently they're
going to make a comeback which i think
is [ __ ] hilarious you know you know
we haven't had a good rape movie in a
while all right
um let's remake Last House on the Left
I think that that needs to be updated
alright anyways bill I had a girlfriend
for about three years well this is the
revenge story bill I had a girlfriend
for about three years winded up cheating
on me
when I found and when I found out about
it I called her out on it and she got
defensive and turned on me
bla bla bla while dude that's that's
some pretty uh she's got skills if she
was able to do that yeah you cheated on
me you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah well you never
do the dishes okay I'm sorry
I guess you made a good point how the
[ __ ] did she turn on you unless she's
alright bill just shut up and read the
story okay well so anyway she turned on
me um then he goes I made the poor
decision and took her back about a year
later about a year later she cheated on
me again and I told her to go [ __ ]
herself prior to the second cheating I
bought a trip to Disney World for us
about eight months after we broke up it
was time for the for the Disney World
trip so I asked her if she wanted to go
she said yes and off we went now my
revenge kicks in see this is just like
one of those movies starts off all nice
and sunny we're going to the camp we're
going to Disneyland and here comes
[ __ ] Jason on a Crystal Lake so now
my revenge kicks in all of the degrading
things I've ever wanted to do this chick
I did to this one again I have guests so
I got to mumble this [ __ ] I busted on a
face I pounded her into the ass until
she puked Jesus Christ women are just
literally ripping their headsets off
right now anyway she goes it was
fantastic on the fourth night we had an
argument she told me that she wanted to
go on this trip to try and win me back
because she felt bad for all the things
she had done to me basically she was
apologizing for cheating when I told her
that there was no chance of us getting
back together and the only reason why I
[ __ ] her was to make her feel like a
prostitute
[Applause]
she bought a plane ticket home and I
felt wonderful I guess what I'm trying
to say is some people deserve what they
get oh god what a great great story
there's so many levels to that ok first
of all just the [ __ ] the fact that
she cheated on you and you took her back
you just like De Niro's character and
casino you know I mean you didn't know
how to handle it and then she cheats on
his second time and then you just become
jaded and you just go into like it was
like you know those movies with a guy
you know the weak person is just getting
the [ __ ] kicked out of them and then
finally they just can't [ __ ] take it
anymore
and then all of a sudden they turn into
like [ __ ] like a Clint Eastwood
character you actually did that with
this girl and then the whole other level
that I love okay is that now that you
finally pound in this skank in bed the
way she always wanted to probably the
reason she cheated on you you know
because you probably would doing that I
love you kind of sex now you actually
[ __ ] do what you were supposed to be
doing with this girl now she wants to
get back with you
[ __ ] that she didn't go to Disneyland
cuz she wanted to get back with you
she went to Disneyland because she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] who saw a free tip to [ __ ]
in Florida and she thought she was going
to play you again and get more [ __ ] out
of you then all of a sudden you come in
there and you throw down like Johnny
[ __ ] wad and now all of a sudden that
then then she wanted to get back with
you and then you told to go [ __ ] herself
which was perfect because I thought you
were going to crumble in that moment and
you didn't you know and then she [ __ ]
left and then that's great and then you
laughed your ass off and jumped on the
teacups listening to it's a small world
after all
you know that's [ __ ] great four stars
if you [ __ ] film that I would not
only would I go see it I would buy it on
DVD great [ __ ] story of revenge
all right there we go had a lot of
passion in it huh oh we're only up to 34
minutes all right let's hustle through
this all right overrated overrated
underrated lists for the week overrated
high-priced Mexican food you can get the
same [ __ ] for half the price across the
street you know some [ __ ] is written so
perfectly I don't even need to add to it
exactly 100 percent correct I still had
to add to it all right
underrated fake boobs [ __ ] awesome I
liked how that's written so short and
it's just up to me to draw my own
collusion my own conclusions fake boobs
[ __ ] awesome
have you ever touched them the [ __ ]
horrific personally I guess I fake boobs
are the worst don't ever do that I don't
ever do that then all of a sudden in the
matter how good they are it's like
you're having sex with a [ __ ] cyborg
one of those awful Bruce Willis movies
members are Judge Dredd you know those
movies where you know they always end up
hooking up with some half person half
robot that's what I feel about that
stuff and I really don't understand why
people get facelifts and stuff you know
first of all it doesn't look good and
everybody noticed even if even if you
you didn't notice for some reason when
you get your facelift it also becomes
really shiny can anybody explain what
that is is that the Botox what is it
about getting facelifts that makes you
face so [ __ ] shiny and it literally
looks like laminated now you know it
looks like it looks like the apples in
the grocery store that they spray to
make them really really shiny speaking
of what you ever get an organic apple I
mean it's like so natural there's like a
[ __ ] worm in it I like the I think I
like the old shiny ones all right bill
love your podcasts just wanted to say I
think using I like this one too bill I
just want to say I think using big words
is overrated if you can express
something by saying a simple normal word
why use a big word I just broke up with
my girlfriend today and earlier she had
called me anthro antral phobic
because I don't know what the [ __ ] that
means because I don't like because I
don't like her friends she called me
answer phobic because I don't like her
friends I just don't like most of her
friends it doesn't mean I hate people in
general or even hate her friends I
honestly didn't know what it meant so I
looked it up it means a fear of people
which isn't even what she said you're
right she didn't even use it correctly
or actually what she or she has a
delusional view of her friends that her
friends represent everybody or that her
friends are so great that if you don't
like them then you just hate all people
because her friends represent humanity
Jesus good movement dumping that [ __ ]
stuck up - what um anyways I definitely
do not like a lot of people but I don't
hate people unlike that caller last week
who mess with that guy's mom mom's car
yeah that guy was [ __ ] nuts anyways
it seems like you're kind of the same
way I just don't see the point of using
big words other than trying to sound
smart it's like if something can be said
more easily in a way that's more easily
understood by using smaller wood words
she became [ __ ] read especially if
you have an idiot like me reading it
keep the word small would you say
something like that Sara Lee killer was
I can't even sigh don't know what this
word is dak nome a dak no maniac or that
sara lee was obsessed with killing i
don't think you'd say either i think you
just say that guy's a serial killer i
mean i think we know what serial killers
do I know you mean dude I know you mean
is what I think I think I think big
words are they're much better in print
you don't I mean because you don't to
read you know a great novel and just
have someone like dude [ __ ] was [ __ ]
up you know I was like damn I mean I
wouldn't to read like I don't I don't
mind I don't mind big words but I mean
they have to be coming out of the right
person's mouth in fact I kind of like
them on some level when you know it but
Carson use a big word and it makes me
want to read and they're actually using
it in an obnoxious way and they for
the right to use it that way because
they actually do read and don't watch TV
but yeah if it's just some chick you
were dating who has kunti friends and
they watched The OC every Thursday night
and then she pulls out a word like that
that sounds like that was a breakup word
she was like I'm going to use a big word
here so I can feel like I'm above this
guy who's dumping me because my low
self-esteem is it is going to [ __ ]
flow right over the side and I'm going
to break down and I'm going to start
crying and I'm gonna have a snot bubble
and I'm gonna feel horrible and I know
in six months I'm going to realize this
person isn't worth crying about so I'm
going to use a [ __ ] big word here to
try to save myself I really forgot what
I was saying halfway through that that's
where I actually agreed with that guy
and then in that scenario I just sort of
trashed him like saying he wasn't worth
he was wasn't worth crying over you know
I don't know [ __ ] about either one of
you but you wrote me the letter so I'm
gonna [ __ ] side with you I'm trying to
be more balanced because I crashed in
this alright hey Bill I've been a big
fan of yours since I saw you feel
special as soon as I was when you going
to come to the punchline in Atlanta well
why don't you go on my [ __ ] website
and scroll down and look for punchline
in Atlanta that's usually a good way to
find out when I'm at the punchline in
Atlanta I'm there in June why do I put
my dates up you know you know why
because 90% of you actually read the
calendar and this [ __ ] guy is not
going to listen to this podcast and he's
going to email me again this week and
you know I'm actually going to send them
an email because I'm a [ __ ] I'll tell
them the exact dates and put a link on
it so I'm just going to shut up anyways
all your [ __ ] is over the let me ask
[Music]
anyway overrated underrated overrated
having kids marriage is bad enough but
for the life of me I can't understand
why the [ __ ] anyone would ever want to
have kids your life effectively ends
when you have kids everything you do has
to be for them how [ __ ] pathetic is
your life that you have that you decide
you know what would be fun never having
any fun anymore
I can't wait to clean [ __ ] out of some
douche
egg infants [ __ ] Jesus Christ only
get four hours of sleep at night if I'm
lucky and never have any [ __ ] fun
with my friends ever again
I mean jesus [ __ ] christ are you
kidding me underrated
this is the same guy maker's mark
whiskey let me guess what you talk about
after you've had a couple of belts from
that anyways he says this [ __ ] is all I
drink and it's [ __ ] spectacular under
forty bucks a handle eighty proof and
smoother than James [ __ ] bond this
guy's great this guy's like the guy's
guy in a youth guy you know what I love
about this dude this is the kind of guy
when you're in a bar and you know you
[ __ ] up your life which is why you go
to the bar and you start drinking and
this is the guy who's going to tell you
when you should face that everything
you're doing is exactly right
he's a guy who comes up what's the
matter man I don't know man I blew with
this chick and he's the guy that you
blew with this chick
what the [ __ ] is wrong you don't want to
be with some [ __ ] broad when you out
of your [ __ ] they just build you up
then you get hammered you get a DUI and
then they take your shoelaces and then
you curl up on that burlap sack they use
for a blanket you wait for your dad to
come down and pick you up you know but
in that moment before all that [ __ ]
happens this this guy's this [ __ ] dude
you know what it is I think as you get
older yet like me I'm starting to really
feel like I want to have a kid now
because it gets pathetic after a while
you know I don't know I don't know if
it's it's the magnetic pull of the herd
you know what I mean everything has like
a gravity to it and I think that as much
as you try to [ __ ] escape the orbit
of the [ __ ] heard you get pulled back
into it and I don't know sometimes I
feel like I'm having too much fun
like as a 40 year old guy and I'm
sitting there you know learning how to
play good times bad times
and I get the NHL package and when I'm
not watching TV I'm learning how to play
ac/dc songs and when I'm not doing that
I'm [ __ ] telling jokes onstage
just gets to the point you like going
like you should start feeling guilty you
know I'm guilty but you just start
looking like you know what I need to
[ __ ] teach someone else how to do
their life like this you know I got to
admit I am a miserable [ __ ] but
I am having I'm having a great time and
you can have it too if you learn how to
talk about your dick on stage
all right last thing bill you started
talking about the police last week and
it got me thinking about them the band
the police all this when I was talking
about all the other music that I missed
out on the police are one of the few
that I listened to um anyways you start
talking about them and so it pulled me
out made me pull out some of my old
records and I started listening to them
and his underrated for the week is he
said sting is a very underrated bass
player most of the bass lines he plays
are amazing I know most people think of
him for his solo work and all the crappy
New Age stuff he does but when he was
with the police he could Rock a bass
like no other yeah I got a miss [ __ ]
I would definitely I don't know if he is
underrated not with musicians he isn't
but I think what people he's underrated
because a lot of people feel that yeah a
lot of his solo stuff is cheesy and
meanwhile he's playing with some of the
bed like Vinnie Colaiuta and all these
[ __ ] guys and I'm a god that sounds
like really lame that that fields a gold
song which every was like people think
of like elevator music has him on bass
and I think Vinnie Colaiuta is actually
playing on drums all right I'm a music
nerd all right and that's it it's ten
o'clock out here and I have to go I
gotta go do some touristy [ __ ] so you
guys I really want to thank you for
continuing to write in the questions the
underrated overrated you guys you know
it's funny you guys I get so good at
this [ __ ] that the podcast I think it
becoming better I'm actually reading out
loud and much better way you guys
actually using punctuation and you tell
me some great stories I'm loving the
stories about revenge
and if you just want to comment on
revenge in general cuz uh you know I
don't know
revenge really that's a line that I I've
never I just don't cry just don't cross
that I just I feel like that is the
deepest darkest part of your soul you
can go into you know yeah [ __ ] you
know you like you like Jimmy Smits on
Dexter you guys watch - Dexter this
season I would recommend a couple of
shows Dexter I liked but uh you got to
watch Brotherhood Showtime on demand you
have to watch that [ __ ] show and it's
just an unbelievable show and there's
actually there's a there's a couple of
guys for season a comedian Tony V that I
learned so much from and another guy
actually started out with Kevin Chapman
who plays Freddie cork who's one of my
favorite characters on that on
television right now I don't if you just
ended gangster [ __ ] shows it's it's
the [ __ ] it's a great [ __ ] show
Brotherhood I'm sure you can rent the
first DVD some even if you even if you
buy it no don't buy it because then you
don't like it then you stuck with it
then I go listen you be a contest but
[ __ ] go rent it somewhere I'm telling
you it's a great show and I'm also into
Breaking Bad
those are my three shows other than that
I just watch sports and and that is it
all right this really tapered off in the
end I hope you guys enjoyed it you guys
have a great week and keep everything
coming and I'll keep doing the podcast
I'll talk to you next week please come
out and see me this Monday night this
coming up Monday the 16th at the
punchline in San Francisco all come and
see me in st. Louis at the house of
comedy in East st. Louis all right I got
a brand new hour and I got a new chunk
of [ __ ] I'm working on all right that's
it take it easy